That's what I wanted to say about components.
In a sense components are easier because, you're going to,
devise them in terms of the functionality, and the functionality is,
dominates what's in the requirements, specification. Connectors are trickier.
Okay. Connectors, are, where the designer has to make some specific choices
about how to deal with problems. Taylor's definition is a, a connector is a,
a software connector is an architectural element tasked with effecting and
regulating interactions among components, the piping between those components.
The key way that I like to look at connectors is they provide a protocol for
interaction among those components. A protocol is a kind of a language saying
who speaks in what order. What information is passed back and forth, and
what to do if something goes wrong. We're going to later in the course,
devote a whole class to discussing connectors.